und jetzt reden wir mal ganz offen und
tabulos über eine gefährliche
parallelgesellschaft die mitten unter
uns entstanden ist ich denke sie
anschauen wovon ich spreche
sie sind ein notorischer motto verein
aus einer mittelalterlichen kultur
unsere gesetze gelten für sie nicht der
button klar
der vatikan meine damen und herren
kleiner gruß aus der wortspiel hölle
dort fand am letzten wochenende der
große anti missbrauchs gipfel statt
ursprünglicher titel war ernst wird es
auch kein witz anstrengungen zum schutz
von minderjährigen in situationen der
anfälligkeit es klingt wie ein ganz
schlimmer schuld roman oder wahnsinn
übrigens nur stunden nur stunden nach
dem gipfel ende haben sie in australien
kardinal george pell in den knast
gesteckt für den missbrauch von zwei
13-jährigen
er wurde erst im letzten jahr aus dem
allerengsten beratergremium des papstes
entfernt und zwar aus altersgründen
meine damen und herren ja immerhin
müssen wir sagen haben sie jetzt endlich
mal über ihre verbrechen geredet danach
erhalten missbrauchsopfer das wort doch
nicht persönlich sondern per tonaufnahme
ja das sieht sich einfach zu sehr runter
wenn du diesen opfern direkt ins gesicht
gucken musste dann lieber eine
tonaufnahme bleibt man schön unter sich
in der texanischen kapelle und leider
leider gab es am ende des gipfels auch
keine konkreten maßnahmen 0
meine man hätte doch wenigstens das
kirchenrecht ändern müssen im sinne von
wer sich an kindern vergeht ist
automatisch nicht mehr priester mehr
vertuscht automatisch nicht mehr bischof
ende tatsächlich sind die vertuscher
noch fast alle im amt und nur sieben
prozent der überführten täter wurden von
der kirche selbst angezeigt nur sieben
prozent hier nagelneue zdf serie
[Musik]
super die körner alter zieht neue miss
ellie beweisen oder nein
doch legt sich zu den anderen schnell so
kritiker die kürzeste krimiserie der
welt jeden sonntag von 19 und 30 bis 19
31 hinzu kämen ja wer sich schnell
vorbei
[Applaus]
gäbe es nicht schnell vorbei im
gegensatz zu den anderen fokus
und natürlich das wird sie nicht
überraschen haben sie bei ihrem gipfel
wieder nicht den zölibat infrage
gestellt ganz offensichtlich genau die
freaks anlockt die ein krankes
verhältnis zu ihrer sexualität haben das
schlimm
meine franziskus war doch der große
reform papst im grunde so was wie der
superheld der katholiken ja und jetzt
und jetzt seine große rede am ende des
gipfels war wirklich ein lehrbeispiel
zum thema wie lenke ich ab vor den
verbrechen meines vereins erstes gebot
beschuldigen deinen nächsten mehr als
sich selbst wer missbrauch begeht sie
vor allem eltern und verwandte die
partner von kinderprojekten trainer
unterziehen
rothaarige skilehrer hobbits in meine es
ist ja es ist ja nicht völlig falsch
aber am thema vorbei
es ging eigentlich um missbrauch in der
kirche wie man den vielleicht etwas
reduzieren könnte stattdessen hatte
ausführlich über sextourismus gesprochen
über internet pornografie und den zitat
gerechtigkeit waren der medien ist die
kirche jetzt das opfer oder was sie das
wusste ich nicht
diese verbrechen gottgeweihte personen
erhalten eine noch dunklere färbung von
untreue und schande und erstelle das
antlitz der kirche die kirche ist
tatsächlich zusammen mit ihren treuen
söhnen und töchtern auch ein opfer
dieser und treue richtig und vw ist
opfer von diesel skandal
ja das ist ja das tolle am katholisch
sein erstens kann man alles beichten und
zweitens ist der schuldige immer ganz
klar dahinter stecke zarten ganz genau
ganz genau
wussten sie gar nicht eine satan hat
pädophile priester über jahrzehnte
stumpf in andere gemeinden versetzt
das war kein mensch solange sich die
kirche nicht endlich ihren systemischen
problemen stellt wird sich da fürchte
ich wenig ändern
das ist meine prognose sag ich mal als
protestant und was und natürlich
natürlich trägt auch unser staat eine
gewisse verantwortung warum schenken wir
nicht polizei in die bistümer und
beschlagen haben alle akten die sie
nicht ausgeben wollen das wäre mal neu
anfangen wenn die kirche soll doch
irgendwann wieder hier
die kirche soll wieder zu einem laib
werden auf den gott zufrieden schauen
kann
ja das wäre schön oder wäre das schön
schallte mal ganz kurz live zu gott und
fragen herr gott schauen sie noch
zufrieden auf die kirche also ganz
ehrlich wilke beiden schaue ich nur noch
ein weg / und abreise zum art wir haben
wirklich ganz und getrunken ja das finde
ich auch vielen dank herr gott danke
schön für den moment der
[Applaus]
beide währungen können bei dieser
veranstaltung der missbrauchs gipfel von
rom und das schlusswort zum thema hat
natürlich wie immer
der heilige vater selbst bietet auch mal
für mich
petit und auf wiedersehen
ja mal zeit wobei schlusswort war eben
glatt gelogen das kommt jetzt von gernot
hassknecht das angebot mit dem krieg der
mythos los
[Applaus]
ja
die mit zuschauer wir freuen uns über
gernot hassknecht einen der ganz wenigen
lebenden deutschen mit lebenslangem
hausverbot im vatikan
er hat heute mal ein paar unverbindliche
vorschläge gott ja hausverbot da geht
man einmal mit badehose in den petersdom
spießer es war die schöne blaue mit bob
der baumeister 3d
wie wär's denn liebe gemeinde wenn wir
endlich mal artikel 138 absatz 1 der
weimarer reichsverfassung umsetzen
darin werden die länder verpflichtet
sämtliche staatsleistungen an die kirche
durch ablösung zu beenden steht da seit
1919 und 100 jahre später zahlen wir
immer noch übrigens in absatz 2 steht
das land berlin ist verpflichtet einen
flughafen zu bauen
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
jetzt haben möchte
artikel 138 wurde ins grundgesetz
übernommen
der gilt aber wir brechen weiter und da
reden wir nicht von kirchensteuer oder
wie ich sie nenne vom schänder
finanzausgleich wir steuerzahler beraten
die gehälter von bischöfen allein im
letzten jahr wohnen 548 millionen davon
228 an die katholen und 320 jahren die
evangelen wofür braucht die evangelische
kirche bitte geld da gucke ich sonntags
morgens doch auf eine unverputzte
klinkerwand pastor
ich gucke gerne drauf und entschuldigung
wenn ich kurz interveniere euer merck
würden nach meinen informationen steht
das den kirchen schon zu juristisch ja
genau
weil die deutschen fürsten die arme
kirche
neulich nämlich 1803 enteignet haben
1803 das ist so lange her da waren viele
der zuschauer noch teenager die deutsche
katholische kirche ist eine der
reichsten der welt zahlt hier null
steuern auf zinserträge und immobilien
ist aber zu geizig ihre missbrauchsopfer
vernünftig zu entschädigen mehr reis
juristen sagen was denen wegen 1803 noch
zusteht liegt irgendwo zwischen 10 und
20 milliarden platz das gibt es von der
leyen in drei minuten für berater aus
überweist ihr euch morgen nach rom und
dann ist aber auch hohen karton könnt
ihr von mir aus wieder ablassen von
verkaufen oder liefert pizza aus jedoch
egal wo ihr eure kohle dann her kriegt
so und jetzt muss ich zum karneval
ich gehe wie immer als bischof kinder
erschrecken viel spaß
guten tag könnte ich sie für ein abo des
heute show youtube kann als begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab sofort